[Applause]
security forces opened fire at crowds in
lagos and there are reports several
people have been killed
amnesty international says it happened
as they tried to disperse demonstrators
ahmed idris reports
just hours after a curfew came into
effect
the security forces started moving in
at the lekital gate in lagos several
different witnesses recorded footage of
what appeared to be
security personnel shooting at
protesters who were blocking a major
highway
a number of people were reported killed
it began as peaceful protest to demand
an end to police brutality
and for two weeks the government
struggled but failed to come
protesters their demands among others
include far-reaching reforms of the
police and the prosecution for officers
accused of extrajudicial killings
torture
and disappearances no care is going
through since we have been protesting we
have not had any reasonable results
so we want out buhari to come and
address us
if not possible
and address the citizens that's what we
can do
we have been trying we have been crying
every day so that they can hear
they can hear our voice but they don't
want to listen to us
but i believe this world are doing we
are going to
get good through good things
and senior lawmakers are lining up
behind some of the protesters demands
i will not sign off on a 2021 budget
that does not include adequate
provisions to compensate those who have
suffered violence
and brutality at the hands of the police
in nigeria in the last
decade which means the country's 2021
budget
could be delayed on monday protesters
blockaded murtara mohammed international
airport lagos
nigeria's busiest
the same day these images appeared of
prisoners among them violent criminals
escaping when two prisons in other
states
were attacked the prison authorities say
nearly 2 000 prisoners have escaped more
warring
is the looting of the armory in the
correction facility here in abuja
nearly two dozen cars were destroyed
already states have started enforcing
24-hour car views
among them the financial capital lagos
which is also home to the country's
busiest ports
this could mean more trouble for an
economy already in a poor shape
the president of the senate has asked
the president to address the nation to
calm the situation
but it's not clear if that will be
enough to placate the protesters
muhammad idris al-jazeera abuja